good morning it's Tuesday so my youtube
friends are visiting the set today
including none other than Kyle I was
actually really pretty I mean I'm
talking about myself yeah you look great
too though thanks buddy it's question
Tuesday the day that I answer real
questions from real nerdfighters except
today I'm gonna ask the questions in
Tyler is going to answer them question 1
zombies or unicorns zombies which
favorite pizza topping
oh I love a ham and pineapple who is
your favorite Beatle The Beatles were a
band you know I don't think I have one
don't people say Ringo and then people
are like Ringo so I think I'm gonna go
with Ringo who's your third favorite
member of One Direction ooh Oh hmm
that's harder than the Beatles one same
two more questions tigers or Lions Oh a
tiger what is the meaning of life um oh
love hi I'm Hannah Hart hi Hannah Hart
what is your favorite movie of all time
the Paper Towns coming soon cats or dogs
cats / dogs my favorite type of dog is a
dog that thinks the cat and doesn't get
so rambunctious what you eat stuffing
I prefer cats what's your biggest phobia
I'm not knowing what to say in response
to a question what do you wanna be when
you grow up a cat lastly what animal do
you prefer wolf or a lion definitely
wolf 100% come on that's a dog I know
that hmm yeah well I ain't lyin
I do love wolves hello I'm in health in
zebras or lions zebras zombies or
unicorns unicorns uh what is your
favorite movie Oh paper child pick a
movie you haven't seen that's smart
that's smart nobody's seen it so nobody
know if it's good yet what's you biggest
oviya spider what do you wanna be when
you grow up an adult hi I'm Amanda
Steele my channel's makeup I'm uni 24
first what's the meaning of life
Pizza zombies or unicorns zombies nice
good choice favorite flavor of pizza why
do I keep calling them flavors when
they're toys yeah pepperoni have you
ever seen a ghost
No are you left-handed no hi I'm Ruth
Janos Rojas my friend and assistant yes
I'm your friend and your sister cause I
have a video book oh you you're a video
blogger yeah cats are dogs cats wolves
are lying signs zombies are unicorns
humming finally god I felt like our
friendship was being challenged what do
you want to be when you grow up this
who's your favorite Beatle maybe Ringo
that's funny you should say that because
Tyler also picked Ringo but only because
he couldn't think of the name of any
other Beatles and lastly I know you're
very British and that you guys don't
have cars there but have you ever been
on a road trip yes when I was in
California and we drove up from LA all
the way up to San Francisco oh yeah
that's not a good trip that's a casual
casual outing yeah I mean that's a
commute for a lot of people hi I'm Chris
Vaughn what favorite movie Moulin Rouge
oh that's a great movie favorite Pete
stopping um
pineapple what's your all-time favorite
city Cape Town what's the meaning of
life be happy and do good hey guys it's
Jen also known as jennxpenn cats or dogs
oh this is so tough for me I think I'm
more of a dog person honestly it's good
that's a good that was a good decision
what's your biggest phobia spiders which
is a classic answer but also Ingrid's
answer really yep I'm terrified
mine is abandonment abandonment no
wonder I was dating a girl and she was
like what's your biggest fear and I was
like abandonment and then I said what's
your biggest fear and she said geese and
I was like oh I see that I have
approached this question incorrectly
I've made a terrible miscalculation
lastly what is the meaning of life find
something that you're passionate about
and do it all the time and love doing it
hey thanks to all of my YouTube friends
for coming to hang out of the favorite
town set today I will see you on Friday